we're ready to jump I do we're here at
the muck fest ms mud run it's an event
to raise money for the National MS
Society and help people fight MS and end
the disease forever I'm ready to win I'm
gonna win this thing well you know it's
a charity mud run you don't need to win
okay
I'm gonna beat net at this that's fine
I've got a whole crew my wife is here
there's so many people that have come
out to support whether it be runners or
volunteers or staff members hello
what does this event mean to you I have
MS so this is a very meaningful to me
one of my best friends has MS and I do
it for the cause we are here with
Theresa casseras we actually were
running next to them for like half of
the the muder on right yes I was
diagnosed with MS in 2007 I get numbness
and tingling I get vertigo and I had
symptoms for about seven years I've had
no idea what it was doctor said I was
fine nothing's wrong with me and I was
adamant I kept just going back to the
doctor until finally they gave me an MRI
and that's what diagnosed me because
this really could have flicked anybody I
could I was I lost all mobility in my
right arm I couldn't pick up a pen I
happened right after I had my son
and yes that's pretty horrible but I
just saw you swinging across ropes and
running through through like muddy
obstacles you're definitely kicking em
SS but for sure I'm sure I'm kicking em
s but so with my daughter and so is it
25 members okay and I just love that all
of my friends had come together everyone
is super enthusiastic I have to live up
the energy everyone's just ready to get
all dirty
it means the world like you're doing
something fun just to continue the the
research is something that can help
millions of people so it's the world to
me what was the most difficult obstacle
for you the one across the lake that was
really cool just walking over jumping
over barrels those fine the one where we
held on it was like at the zipline oh
the zipline yeah I did a front flip into
the water at that point being tagged and
then being tackled the general rope rope
net climb Oh was that like it was it was
easy I mean the reason I come here is
because I love laughing and I love
seeing my dad running through the mud
and just laughter every day gets me
through do some research realize that it
affects so many people and a society has
their website you can also look up
Macbeth demouth it's all over the
country we just did a mud run make so
much to the National MS Society for
everyone that won the fight MS roof
we're dragon
yeah water yeah I watch it but alone
when you can wash your boat with friends